الأجانب
هنا عابرون ، هذه الرقصة يمكن أن تكون
آخر الجنود الروس الذين يعيشون هنا يعيشها معظم المدانين قبل
ساعات من إرسالهم إلى
الخطوط الأمامية ، يقاتلون من أجل
العفو ، لكن هنا أكثر من نصفهم ماتوا في
الجبهة حتى قال بعض الناجين حتى بعد أن
عاشوا خلال
تم سجن معارك سافانا بتهمة السطو المسلح
والاعتداء ، لكن تم إخراجها من السجن
وإلقاءها في أسوأ قتال خارج
سوليداد ، حيث كانت
وحدته مازحة هنا قبل أن يهاجموا
مصنعًا في اليوم التالي وتعرضوا
لخسائر كارثية أخبر زوجته
فيكتور نجا ولكن بينما كان مصابًا بجروح.  في
المستشفى ، كان يخشى أن يتم جره من
سريره وإعدامه لسوء
الأداء ، فهذه هي رسالته الأخيرة إلى
زوجته
[موسيقى].
مدفونون هنا خارج موسكو ،
هناك شيء مختلف تمامًا
عن سافانا بالنسبة للعديد من السجناء الذين تم
إرسالهم إلى الخطوط الأمامية للتعويض عن
الخسائر المدمرة لروسيا ،
يتم إرسال معظمهم من قبل
المقاول العسكري الخاص الغامض واغنر الذي يحرص في هذا
الفيديو الدعائي على تصوير
ناجين نادرين يعودون  سعيد
بالامتنان حتى وزعم الأسبوع الماضي أنه
توقف عن التجنيد في السجون
تمامًا ، لكن سافانا والعديد من
المدانين الذين تحدثت إليهم سي إن إن قالوا إنهم
استأجروا من السجن مباشرة من قبل
وزارة الدفاع الروسية ، إنه
استخدام رائع للمدانين مباشرة من قبل
موسكو والمخابرات الأوكرانية تقول
إنه  أسرهم على خط المواجهة
حتى بين أسرى الحرب الروس في
أوكرانيا ، هناك الآن من تم تجنيدهم
في الشركات الخاصة التابعة
لوزارة الدفاع في
الاتحاد الروسي ، وأكدوا لنا أنهم
ليسوا فاغنر ولكنهم
مدعوون رسميًا من قبل وزارة الدفاع
هنا نسمع  أصداء
الخلافات الداخلية في وجود القيادة العسكرية الروسية
لفاغنر يتم خداعها مع
المدانين الذين يسيطر عليهم مباشرة
رؤساء الدفاع في شويغو وغاراسانوف ، وقد أدى
التجنيد إلى زيادة هذه
الأرقام الحكومية التي أظهرت انخفاضًا مفاجئًا في
عدد نزلاء السجون بمقدار 27000 في العام الماضي عندما
كان المخطط للتو.  جاريًا مع عدم وجود
عفو واضح لشرح ذلك ، فقد
ماتت نسبة كبيرة مع
مقطع فيديو تدريب واغنر هذا الذي يظهر أحد
التكتيكات المتهورة التي يستخدمها السجناء
للتقدم إلى الأمام معًا عند العدو
سافالنيف كان جزءًا من وحدة تسمى صفر
ثمانية ثمانية صفر سبعة
وخطوطها الأمامية الأخرى  يعرف الناجون مدى صعوبة
البقاء على قيد الحياة تحت إشراف وزارة
الدفاع ، وقد
تحدثنا إلى العديد من
أسرتهم في المستشفى لإخفاء هويتهم ، وصف
جندي سابق مسجون بتهم تتعلق بالمخدرات ،
وصفه بأنه تم إعادته مرتين إلى
الجبهة بينما
كنا مصابين نتجول مصابين بطلقات نارية
بشظايا.  عالقون في أرجلنا ، لم يتم
إجراء أي عملية جراحية على أحد ، كنا 130 شخصًا ولكن
لدينا العديد من مبتوري الأطراف ، ربما كان أقل
من 40 فردًا منا قد أدينوا بالقتل غير
العمد ، يقول نصف وحدته أصبحوا
ضحايا لقد تم إرسالنا إلى
الجبهة الأمامية ، لقد اتصلت بأفرادنا بأنهم كانوا
أطلقوا قذائف الهاون علينا بحيث يجب أن
يصوبوا قليلاً إلى اليمين وما زالوا
يطلقون النار علينا من كلا الجانبين ، ثم أدركت أنهم كانوا يطلقون النار علينا عمدًا ،
إنها خطة تجنيد في
فخ كل من يستطيع بعضهم ليس
روسيًا
في الحفل المدرسي  يكرم واغنر
الطالب التنزاني نيمس توريمو الذي تم
اعتقاله بتهمة المخدرات أثناء
تبادل دراسي هنا في
حدث عيد الميلاد في المربع الأحمر في نظام عدالة
معروف بالفساد ،
قالت عائلته في تنزانيا إنهم لم
يعرفوا حتى أنه تم اعتقاله عندما
علموا أنه  قُتل في الحرب
منذ أن كان نيم طفولته
صبيًا مطيعًا للغاية ، لقد كان هروبًا ، لقد كان
شخصًا متدينًا للغاية عندما كان على قيد الحياة
لم نسمع عنه أبدًا ، ولكن الآن بعد
وفاته ، قيل لنا إنه تم القبض عليه
بتهمة المخدرات.  الإهانات ، إنها
تؤلمنا حقًا كعائلة
لم يكن يحلم بها أبدًا في أن يصبح
جنديًا ، وقد
أُعيد جسده مغلقًا في القبر ،
قصة أخرى عن كيفية التخلص من الحياة
في المقدمة نيك بايتون والش سي إن إن
لندن